welcome to this video playing FM zaps a
higher rating who is that let me check
Sebastian mikhaylov I added some that's
a younger guy from from from Norway I
think that's a different flag right
Costa Rica ok let's go I played him no
never played in before I feel I that I
have played them but statistics says
otherwise says otherwise that correct
English yeah the statistic doesn't
confirm my hunch so we get the huebner
variation one main feature of my opening
book at least I feel I know what I'm
doing there where did I spend 21 seconds
hmm it's been strange to be honest I
felt like a plate rather quickly ok
anyway let's see what is so near route
be one that's uncommon hmm ok that is a
decent reply in almost all cases 91 hmm
and you can go 98 or 96 in general
against that move like Nigeria now yeah
you can go Bishop 83 this is not sorry
for that that is not really a
theoretically um explored position but
the ideas are kind of kind of similar in
some of the lines so f 5 is going to
play F form okay it's not the end of the
world
let's see okay he threatening to check
on f5 maybe okay I cannot play Knight f6
that's a bit unfortunate yeah okay going
to take here let's a debatable decision
quite clearly I'm not totally sure how i
should play here yeah 95 I wonder if 96
something that really helps them or not
let's let's play the move it's not not
quite clear to me maybe bishop see
towards the move that you can play
preserving that bishop and just giving
away the sea porn are threatening to
take and take on a form really well that
looks fine doesn't it Queen takes Bishop
f5 is Sam is nice I don't get it what is
the point 96 it's a funny tactic
because of that that mating idea that's
cute night is sex hardcore so anyway I'm
if I should f 596 Bishop is six ok wait
King evade d takes is six I wonder if
that is any good I can take with the
rock that's not a huge problem I think
but that wasn't hit the original idea
funny funny tactical point 96 so it's
Knight f6 move now I said maybe it is a
move he cannot go G for now ah sorry Jen
so my voice is kind of failing me okay
didn't know no big joy see him they have
to take that gotta take six otherwise
check doesn't make any sense maybe
rookie five would have been interesting
but okay I have to be a little bit and a
bit quicker so that
needed some some drink um so that I'm
not falling too far behind on the clock
looks a tad passive but i was thinking
like h6 rook f6 and i might be able to
get that pawn so aged 6 here and no
after night c7 he has it does he have
queen to d6 at the end he scattered
Bishop e7 in this line that's kind of
annoying night c7 queen d 6 Queen takes
Bishop takes but i can go rookie sex
right at the anti Scott Bishop p8 night
f 86 97 a4 and I should be okay their
nights seven takes takes rookie six okay
that's not working that's all I didn't
see that move coming ah very very stupid
not taking or candidate moves into
account I was just thinking of the other
line which probably was okay I don't
have a move here now time morning what a
shame now okay played it well always
keeping some pressure
yeah so still very unnecessary probably
to lose that game you can just take it
seven I guess check
hmm yeah maybe that's stronger I'm not
not quite sure it's difficult for me to
make any moves there cannot move the
King cannot take I can take on this 647
check yeah I see it now and he will see
it as well yes of course okay black
resigns yeah checks losses yeah okay it
wasn't not really necessary to lose that
game but he kept some pressure for for a
long time I had some some nice ideas
don't think that I have problems here to
be honest yeah this is just good yeah
like it's better now I can get that porn
yeah would have been I would have been
strange of something really bad had
happened here it looks like a normal
position 1960s he has to check here
maybe yeah he's doing the move I i
understand i'm better here for that
that's clear he had to get to take on f5
but here but here only black can be
better probably probably it's equal ish
getting getting that back here yeah he
will enter it's an interesting position
but if i get the D porn um in this in
this position it's probably equal how I
can just take and it's equal yeah that's
that's going to be going to be just
equal yeah but you played that well some
interesting ideas here with 96 my
original intention will of course to do
this but then 96 is kind of awkward yeah
checkmate needle made daffa take the
Queen okay the engine gives Queen f6 as
ok but i don't know i mean look at five
was totally fine there's nothing wrong
with this position this him check ya
after rookie 5 i'm just winning this
pawn yeah i saw it but it's too late
just too late no he has some some
compensation for sure now that's a
typical line check yeah black is better
he will get there is a porn but i still
have the better structure oaq Kenny ok
that's also possible yeah he's dashing
out those moves some just a question how
much better blog is there no I don't
think an interesting interesting game
after I made that mistake um yeah rookie
one is better and probably something
like this he's writing good game yep he
was an interesting game chat i want to
check actually how bad this is and i
don't think it is that bad let's just
see maybe maybe i'm wrong it looks to
bed passive but i was thinking i could
maybe get get these six pawn maybe
that's simply not the case and and i'm
wrong yeah okay that's it interesting so
oh it's a draw oh that's funny I didn't
see that that this is actually a draw
check how is this a troll can I shake
him there he will escape when the engine
gives this funny move threatening g4
made now that's a draw according to the
comp and the computer will be right here
the point is that if you t assets in
immediate raw what exactly are you doing
haha interesting but Queens is Queen B
seven then was a it was a move that
throw threw me off balance but it wasn't
wasn't really that great and I saw that
correctly that this is probably going to
be okay I was looking at that line he
had this and here now I'm threatening to
come all the way over pick that up it
should be at least okay for black but ok
played that which is really not really
good then but yeah it was Chatham Utley
winning the game yeah okay that that
blundered that was a blonde of it it's
difficult we need to make a move here in
this position the engine suggest a six
which is not very attractive this is one
one point that is Chad annoying any
plane did well was an interesting game
thanks for watching